[Music]
peyton is in portland maine hi peyton
welcome to the ramsay show
hey john uh how are you guys great man
what's up
so i have a little bit of a relationship
question with my about my parents i'm
20. um i just finished school i work
full-time um i'm on baby step two right
now so i'm paying off uh my student
loans
and my car i just i'm almost done paying
off my car right now um i had an account
statement on my counter
and my parents saw and they seemed they
seemed almost disappointed that i'm
paying off the debt because they really
they're really
worried about my credit score but you
know i don't know how to
explain to them like the plan i'm doing
with you guys i've tried to before but
it just doesn't seem to register and
they were really it seems like they were
really disappointed i just didn't know
how to go about that it kind of took me
back
um i know in my heart i'm doing the
right thing but i want to be able to
honor them
with doing this because they think i'm
being irresponsible
so i'm just not sure how to go about
dealing with that situation with them
how old are you now did you say 20 20 uh
20. all right you live at home
i do yes okay i'm gonna give you a gift
well this is gonna give you a gift and
it's gonna be a little bit complicated
because you live at home but i want you
to keep this near and dear to your heart
okay
they don't get a vote
you're out of college you got a job
you're making a living now they do get a
vote because right now you live in their
house and so if they tell you to be home
at nine o'clock and to fold your socks a
certain way you live in their house and
they can do that but when it comes to
how i'm taking care of my money my dad
has opinions which is fine well and good
but me and my wife make decisions
financially for my household
and you're making your own money you're
making your own job you're paying off
your own debts and they can tell you hey
we think you should do this and really
care about this loan and what
thank you so much for your wisdom i'm
really grateful for that i have a
relative that tells me how i should vote
and they're wrong
[Laughter]
so they don't get a vote okay and what
you what you if man if you can learn
this at 20 that people who love you and
care about you are going to give you bad
advice and they still love you and care
about you and you're going to be able to
move on with your day i mean if you
could
i didn't figure that out until i was
like 35. so if you can figure that at 20
the rest of your life is going to be
good because this is going to continue
to happen that way okay yeah yeah and so
here's the thing um
you know mom and dad i don't want to
disappoint you guys and i know that you
don't understand what i'm doing here
uh and i love you and i respect you uh
but i actually do have a system and i
actually am working a plan uh
from some reading and some studying that
i've been doing on how to handle money
and it's working for me
so i know you don't understand but it's
okay i'm gonna be okay and if i'll be
happy to talk to you about it but i'm
but you you need to separate the part
where you need their you emotionally
need their approval
to be an adult that's what john's saying
okay
a great gift man i sometimes when i'm
trying to explain a hard concept you
know if i'm talking to somebody and i'm
i just don't have the words to explain
it i'll hand them a book and say this
guy or a podcast this guy does it better
than me she this this brilliant doctor
she writes this better than i can
explain it right now and so maybe if you
say hey if you don't fully understand i
get it here's a copy of total money
makeover read this this guy there's a
better job explaining
millionaires that's right just do a
better job of explaining it to me yeah
that's not a bad thing to do either and
go this is what i'm doing and if this
helps you it might be interesting to you
it might not you may just want to stand
back and not agree and that's okay too
you can do whatever you want to do i'm
just i'm going to be going forward with
this thing
and it's a smile and a gentle word no
fights
no there's no
acid in the air no passive aggressive in
the
question or the statement
just
be there